in 2018 coal production is set to end in
Germany for now it's business as usual
for these miners in the West German
[ __ ] region but in three years their
workplace might look very different
scientists are looking at a pumped
storage power plant to replace these
mines this would entail turning mine
tunnels and shafts into underground
storage spaces for water geologist Alva
Kaiba says it can be done he has done
research into converting mines into
renewable energy producers we were able
to show in our first development study
that it's technically possible to build
a pumped storage power plant underground
that means we have the volume
infrastructure and technical
capabilities we won't be using anything
that still has to be developed pumped
storage power plants are known proven
and necessary pumped storage power
plants can provide energy even when the
Sun isn't shining or the wind blowing
water is drained from an above-ground
reservoir into a shaft with turbines at
the bottom these convert the force of
the falling water into electricity once
the Sun and wind provide enough energy
their power would be used to pump the
water back up to the reservoir the mines
infrastructure first has to be removed
to make room for the pump storage power
plant that could cost between 200 to 500
million euros without subsidies however
investors will probably be hard to find
still German company our AG which runs
coal production in this region says it
is interested in turning the site into a
source of renewable energy
for the state of North rhine-westphalia
which describes itself as an energy
state this great project would be a
feather in its cap also internationally
uncertain that it will not only be a
worthy investment but one that will pay
off if a pumped-storage power plant is
built here this new use for old coal
production sites could turn into export
success after all coal is mined all
around the world coal mines are on their
way out
utility masts are still standing and
more windmills are coming underground
energy storage made in Germany may be on
its way to